so two weeks ago i made a video
discussing why i would be voting for
president trump but now i want to
discuss why no one
should vote for joe biden come on man
before we begin i just need to give a
quick shout out to our friends over at
raycon who sponsored this video
stick around for a special offer from
our friends at raycon there are
essentially four reasons why you should
not vote for
joe biden first he is a typical
washington dc politician with all of the
corruption that entails second
he has been wrong on every major foreign
policy issue like ever his entire life
third
he has no bulwark of moderation he has
shifted left on every
major policy issue on which he has ever
spoken and finally his actual agenda the
one he has stated is wildly
and radically to the left okay so let's
start with who is joe biden biden was
born in 1942
a long time ago in scranton pennsylvania
his family moved to delaware when he was
nine
he was a self-described poor student in
high school he was popular he was
elected student class president i
believe when he was in high school he
went to university of delaware he was
ranked 506th in a class of 688
he went to syracuse college of law he
ranked 76 out of a class of 85
which just shows you that our political
class they're not always bringing the
intellectual best he received a draft
deferment from vietnam while he was in
school
he won his first senate race in 1972
when he was 29 years old that was the
same year that his wife and daughter
naomi were
killed in an automobile accident which
of course is a massive tragedy
his sons were in the car and they were
injured as well biden subsequently
married jill in 1977.
he became ranking member of the senate
judiciary committee in 1981 and ran for
president
in 1987 but he flamed out amidst
accusations of exaggeration
and plagiarism so what was joe biden
like when he was in congress well
he was ambitious right he was the father
of so-called borking
he was the guy in charge of the senate
judiciary committee when they decided to
basically make it impossible for anybody
to openly state
that they were in favor of the
constitution as written and interpreting
it as written as a judge
joe biden brags about that now he says
he was happy that he kept robert bork
off the court if you like all of the
insanity surrounding our judicial
nominations you can blame joe biden he
started it
i was part of the reason why elena kay
gonna work for me got on the supreme
court
i was part of the reason why ruth bader
ginsburg is on the court i was part of
the reason why sort of my heirs on the
court and she
swore me in i presided and i'm the
reason why
this right wasn't taken away a long time
ago because i
almost single-handedly made sure that
robert bork did not
get on the court because he did not
think there should be enumerated rights
okay that was one of the most egregious
acts in the history of judicial
nominations and
biden braggs about it he tried the same
thing against clarence thomas he tried
to railroad thomas on anita's hill's
unsupported charges of sexual harassment
thomas
suggested that essentially biden was
throwing bean balls at him
that biden was being unfair to him which
of course was true later biden would
apologize
to anita hill for not being harsher on
clarence thomas and of course
joe biden has a very long habit of
putting his foot in his mouth i know
that now we are all supposed to believe
he's a golden tongue to orator but until
five minutes ago everybody understood
that joe biden was a walking joke
here's just a few of joe biden's
favorite gaffes you got the first
sort of mainstream african-american
yeah who is articulate and bright and
and clean and a nice looking guy you
cannot go to
a 7-eleven or a dunkin donuts
unless you have a slight indian accent
as far as the idea that joe biden is
just a nice guy aside from borking bork
and going after clarence thomas
you'll remember that joe biden also said
that mitt romney is going to re-enslave
black people so that was exciting stuff
he's going to let the big banks once
again write their own rules
unchain wall street
[Music]
they're going to put you all back in
chains okay so that kind of sums up his
political career up till
this point in terms of what he had done
right he was a senator for a really long
time then he was barack obama's vice
president
he ran for president as i say in 1987
1988 he was basically thrown out of the
campaign when it was discovered that he
was a plagiarist he was a serial
plagiarist actually he plagiarized not
just from neil kinnick he was a british
politician about his personal life story
he also plagiarized from rfk
and that brought up other plagiarism
issues and exaggeration issues he
suggested he'd been a civil rights
marcher none of that was true
all of that is kind of usual politics
then you get to joe biden's corruptions
when we talk about
usual politics of corruption joe biden's
there right he's a washington dc
swamp creature and this has been known
for a long time there's nothing
new here okay joe biden i know now
everybody is talking about joe biden and
hunter
this has been a kind of skeleton in joe
biden's closet nearly his entire
political career members of his family
using his name in order to make bank so
going back to 2008 mainstream media
outlets were
reporting on joe biden's family
corruption cbs news reported quote
a son of democratic vice presidential
candidate joe biden was paid an
undisclosed amount of money as a
consultant by mbna the largest employer
in delaware
during the years the senator supported
legislation that was promoted by the
credit card industry and opposed by
consumer groups
consumer and civil rights groups and
unions as well as democratic opponents
had argued that the bankruptcy
legislation was unfair to low-income
working people single moms minorities
and the elderly and would remove a
safety net for those who have lost their
jobs or face mounting medical bills
mbna employees poured more than 200 000
into biden senate campaigns over the
past two decades making donors working
for the credit card company the
senator's largest
source of campaign money and of course
biden was receiving sweetheart real
estate deals from
mbna himself michelle malkin reporting
for national review in 2010 wrote
former senior senator from delaware and
current vice president joe biden has a
custom-built house in delaware's
ritziest chateau country
neighborhood it is now worth at least
2.5 million bucks is the biden's most
valuable asset
biden tapped campaign funds to pay for
his compound's lawn needs he secured the
new estate with the help of a corporate
executive who worked for biden's top
campaigns owner
credit card giant mbna in 1996 biden
sold his previous mansion to mbna vice
chairman john cochran
the asking price was 1.2 million cochran
forked over the full sum
biden then paid 350 grand in cash to
real estate developer keith stoltz
for a 4.2 acre lakefront lot stilts had
paid that same amount five years earlier
for the undeveloped property
joe biden's family spent decades cashing
in on his name according to the
left-wing site the intercept
in 2006 beau biden who died of cancer in
was roped into an investment meeting led
by james and hunter biden at the firm
paradigm global advisors
the family was considering acquiring the
firm james biden told executives he'd
have no problem bringing in people
looking for an in
with joe biden who was a us senator at
the time james biden told officials
according to a
political magazine investigation quote
we've got people all over the world who
want to invest
in joe biden james also in the 90s
founded a group called lion hall
which lobbied for mississippi trial
lawyers involved in tobacco litigation
according to curtis wilkie's book the
fall of the house of zeus the trial
lawyers wanted
james biden's help pushing joe biden on
tobacco legislation and of course then
there's hunter who's run around picking
up bags of cash from everybody from mbna
to barisma in fact here's hunter biden
admitting the only reason he was even on
the barisma board is because his last
name is biden
if your last name wasn't biden do you
think he would have been asked to be on
the board of burisma
i don't know i don't know probably not i
i don't think that there's a lot of
things that would have happened in my
life that uh
that if my last name wasn't fine so
supposedly joe biden knew nothing about
any of this right
hunter was just picking up rides on air
force two to china and then picking up
million dollar deals over there
and hunter biden was traveling over to
kazakhstan and to ukraine and just
picking up these bags of cash everywhere
but joe biden knew nothing about any of
these deals well now tony bobolinsky who
is
hunter biden's business partner in a
failed chinese venture he says no
joe is pretty well aware of this stuff
that's a blatant lie when he states that
that is a blatant lie
obviously the world's aware that i
attended the debate last thursday
and in that debate he made a specific
statement
around questions around this from the
president
and i'll be honest with you i almost
stood up and screamed liar
and walked out because i was shocked so
bottom line here is that joe biden's a
swamp creature right he's a typical
washington dc swamp creature
he is embedded in low level to high
level corruption he's been
willing to green light his family's
corruption for a long time then we get
to joe biden on policy
so a few things to know about joe biden
on policy okay first reason not to vote
for biden typical
dc politician swamp creature reason
number two not to vote for joe biden
he's been wrong on every foreign policy
issue of his entire lifetime
i'm not the one saying that obama
defense secretary robert gates said that
just a few years back again that was
obama's defense secretary who served
with joe biden saying that
you said in your memoir joe biden is
impossible
not to like quote he's a man of
integrity
incapable of hiding what he really
thinks and one of those rare people you
know you could turn to for help in a
personal crisis
still i think he's been wrong on nearly
every
major foreign policy and national
security issue over the past
four decades would he be an effective
commander-in-chief
i i don't know i don't know i
i think i stand by that statement so
let's go through this
okay so in iraq joe biden supported the
war in iraq right he did
he spoke out favorably for it he said it
was really really important
he talked about supporting president
bush then he says that colin powell made
a compelling case for the war
in iraq that was in 2003 by 2005
biden was saying the iraq war was a
mistake right it was a big mistake by
2005 because of course joe biden shifts
with the wind by 2019 biden was openly
lying about this stuff saying that he
started opposing the war
the moment shock and awe started which
of course is not true he continued to
support the war
after that and here's joe biden in 2019
just lying about his opposition to the
iraq war
i did make a bad judgment trusting the
president saying he was only doing this
to get inspectors in
and get the un to agree to put
inspectors in from the moment
shock and awe started from that moment i
was opposed to the effort and i was
outspoken
as much as anyone at all in the congress
and administration
overt lie not true okay then by 2006
biden opposed the iraq search right so
the iraq surge was a really really bad
idea
by the way that's the only thing that
made iraq anything close to
uh a a success then by 2010
biden was in favor of precipitously
pulling troops out of iraq he said it
would be a great obama achievement
of course we all remember if we have
memories long enough that
the pull out from iraq ended with the
rise of isis so it's actually one of the
worst things the obama administration
did here was joe biden in 2010 praising
it
i am very optimistic about
about iraq i think it's going to be one
of the great achievements of this
administration you're going to see
90 000 american troops come marching
home by the
end of the summer you're going to see a
stable government in iraq that is
actually moving toward
a representative government okay all of
that is just him being wrong
from every conceivable angle on rock
like every angle
then there's afghanistan so in 2009
biden opposed obama's afghanistan surge
he was the only person in the cabinet to
do so apparently then in 2011
biden acknowledged that he had opposed
the raid that ended with the killing of
osama bin laden which is nearly
impossible to do like that's the easiest
call in the history of foreign policy
and biden blew that one here's by and
admitting he blew it
i said we owe the man a direct answer mr
president my suggestion is don't go
we have to do two more things to see if
he's there okay let's move to libya
so biden in 2011 said that nato got it
right in libya in fact libya was a great
success story as opposed to george w
bush in iraq
forget about the fact that libya
immediately collapsed into utter chaos
ending with the burning of the us
embassy in benghazi and the murder of
four americans including
ambassador chris stevens also wrong on
russia
in 2012 biden openly mocked the idea of
russia as an adversary
because mitt romney had said that russia
was a geopolitical threat to the united
states biden said no
none of that they're they're our friends
guys they are our friends
now of course russia is the big bad
bogey man in the closet but at the time
biden was handing over control of syria
to russia he was handing over control of
crimea to russia he and obama were
pledging flexibility to russia
so he's been wrong on that he was wrong
on iran in 2015.
joe biden praised the iran deal said the
iran deal was a godsend it was going to
create peace
in the middle east i've come to the
conclusion that in the context i've just
cited that this is a good deal
this is a good deal for the first and
foremost for the united states
it's a good deal for the world the
region and it's a good deal for
israel and the gulf cooperation states
it's a good deal turns out the iran deal
was a giant mess
all it did was fund a terrorist regime
that was using that money in order to
kill american soldiers abroad and foster
its terrorism all over the middle east
by the way the fostering of that
terrorism ended
ironically with middle east peace
between many arab countries in israel
who had to oppose iran
then in 2020 biden came out and ripped
donald trump for killing kasem tulane
who was the head of the terror network
in iran he said yeah salman is a bad guy
but this is for sure going to create
retaliation
it brings us closer to the brink of war
none of that was true right he literally
said
that this will have the opposite effect
of deterring future attacks
from iran he said he tossed a stick of
dynamite into a tinderbox that was
biden's phraseology dead wrong on that
okay on china biden said in 2019 that
china is not competition for the united
states which is weird because um they
are
china is going to eat our lunch
come on man they can't even figure out
how to deal with the the the fact that
they have
this great division between the china
sea and the mountains in the east
i mean in the west they can't figure out
how they're going to deal with the
corruption that exists within the system
i mean i you know they're not bad folks
folks but guess what
they're not a cut they're not
competition for us hey on israel
biden has always taken the view that
being harsh with israel and its
negotiations with palestinian terror
groups is a good idea
and now in 2020 after it is perfectly
obvious and clear
that the move of the us embassy to
jerusalem was a good move and had no
downsides
joe biden still says he wouldn't have
moved the u.s embassy to jerusalem this
is an administration that as you know
advocated moving the capital
of israel to jerusalem from tel aviv if
you are elected president
would you reverse that not now i
wouldn't reverse it i wouldn't have done
it in the first place
so bottom line is this robert gates is
right biden's been wrong on every major
foreign policy issue of his entire
lifetime
all right more on the reasons why you
should not vote for joe biden in just a
second
but first i have to tell you about
something fabulous something incredible
something
these right here you see these in my
hand these are raycons and these are
going to be your favorite wireless
earbuds just as they are my
favorite wireless earbuds so many
celebrities love these wireless earbuds
these raycons in fact
the only thing that platinum
award-winning rappers like me and cardi
b have in common
is our love for raycon raycon the
everyday e25 earbuds these are the best
earbuds
on the market six hours of playtime
bluetooth they're wireless earbuds they
come in a range of fun colors and
patterns they're super comfortable they
come with a variety of fit options
the compact carrying case it can charge
earbuds four times on a single charge
unlike some of those other wireless
options raycon earbuds are stylish and
discreet no dangling wires no stems they
are great
for video chats one of the things i love
is they're going to fit your ear
perfectly because they have a variety of
fits you can really customize them
so they fit properly and raycon earbuds
start at about half the price
of any other premium wireless earbuds on
the market they sound just as amazing as
other top audio brands you know
raycons are great from working from home
working out listening to music and
podcasts
check out their everyday e25s i say six
hours of playtime seamless bluetooth
pairing
more bass more compact design that gives
you that nice noise isolating fit it
also comes in
new fun colors click the link in the
description below get 15
off your order again click that link
down below and 15
off your order
okay then we get to his domestic policy
so there's one constant theme
to joe biden's domestic policy he's
constantly evolving which is to say
he abandons every position as soon as it
becomes politically unpalatable
so look at his history on crime and
drugs in 1982 biden explicitly told
ronald reagan
to ramp up drug enforcement in fact he
said ronald reagan wasn't doing enough
on drug enforcement then in 1989 he
suggested we needed more drug
enforcement we needed longer sentences
for criminals we needed to lock up drug
dealers here's joe biden saying that
i think the president has to join us in
making a significantly greater
commitment to these six areas to stem
the rising tide of violence in america
and that's what it is violence
first we have to join together to ensure
the drug dealers are punished
swiftly surely and severely in line with
what the president is calling for
we have to hold every drug user
accountable
because if there were no no drug users
there would be no appetite for drugs
there'd be no market for them
in 1993 joe biden became one of the
chief sponsors of the
1994 congressional crime bill which
lengthened sentences
created mandatory minimums and all that
it was actually a good bill
but don't worry you'll see as times
shift so does joe biden
in 2010 biden stood with the
criminalization of marijuana in 2016
biden was still defending the 1994
crime bill but by 2019-2020 things had
changed right the nature of the
democratic party had changed
and now joe biden was apologizing for
the crime bill
in 2019 he said i'm sorry about that it
was just a big mistake
said joe biden he said i haven't always
been right i know we haven't always
gotten things right but i've always
tried
it was a big mistake when it was made oh
weird because um that was the signal
achievement of your congressional career
he also flipped on marijuana he had said
that marijuana was bad now marijuana
ought to be decriminalized and he
flipped on the death penalty as well
so virtually every criminal justice
stand he's ever held he has flipped on
the same thing is true on abortion in
1973-74 biden supported getting rid of
roe versus wade he said that the
decision went too far
he said in 1974 he didn't think a woman
has the sole right to say what should
happen to her body
okay as late as 2019 biden was still
defending the hyde amendment
right he was saying that abortion should
not be federally funded in the united
states
then it became politically unpalatable
to say that and so he flipped
and denounced the hyde amendment i can't
justify leaving millions of women
without access to the care they need
and the ability to const to exercise
their constitutionally
protected right if i believe health care
is right as i do i can no longer support
an amendment
that makes that right dependent on
someone's zip code by 2020
he'd moved all the way from roe versus
wade is a bad decision so we need to
codify row in federal law
because his party is now the party of
unrestricted abortion on every level
considering the new supreme court
nomination of amy
um tony barrett what are your particular
plans to protect
women's reproductive rights in the u.s
number one
we don't know exactly what she will do
although expectation is that
she may very well move to overview
overview
over rural row and but the only thing
the only
responsible response to that would be to
pass legislation
making roe the law of the land that's
what i would do
on immigration joe biden shifted in 2006
joe biden suggested not only building
700 miles offense
he also suggested that we ought to
prosecute companies for hiring illegal
immigrants
i voted for offense i voted like unlike
most democrats and some of you won't
like it i voted for 700 miles
but let me tell you we can go to things
40 stories high
unless it changes the dynamics
in mexico and and
you will not like this and punish
american employers who knowingly
violate the law when in fact they hire
illegals now of course joe biden says he
will make daca permanent on the very
first day
he is in office okay on gay marriage joe
biden evolved
okay but he didn't really evolve okay
let's just be frank about this
everything in joe biden's career is
he follows the prevailing wins in his
party which makes a big difference
because
remember his pitch is that he is a
bulwark against the radicals
no he absolutely is not on gay marriage
in 93 he voted for a bill deeming
homosexuality incompatible with military
service
the don't ask don't tell though in 96
biden voted for the defense of marriage
act protecting traditional marriage
by 2012 he had shifted now he was
pushing same-sex marriage as a trial
balloon on behalf of the obama
administration
you're comfortable with same-sex
marriage now i i look
i am vice president united states of
america um the president
sets the policy i am absolutely
comfortable
with the fact that men marrying men
women
marrying women and heterosexual men and
are entitled to the same exact rights
all the civil rights all the civil
liberties
and quite frankly i don't see much of a
distinction
beyond that that was not a matter of
principle for joe biden it was a matter
of as always political expedience
on literally every topic joe biden is
willing to shift his stance every single
one
in 96 he voted for welfare reform by
2020 his campaign would not answer
where he even was on welfare reform okay
so bottom line is this if you're
trusting joe biden to be a bulwark
against the radical left
you're stupid that is an idiotic idea
he's not a bulwark against the radical
left so to recap
he's a typical washington dc corrupt
insider too he's been wrong on every
foreign policy issue he has ever touched
three he's evolved on every position
toward the radical left
when the incentives were aligned and
finally four
joe biden's already making clear that
the agenda is aligning on behalf of the
radical left not only
has he suggested that america is
systemically racist his actual plans are
as bernie sanders says
to the left of franklin roosevelt of fdr
of lbj
it is the most progressive platform in
american history according to bernie
sanders
biden's tax plan according to the tax
foundation's general equilibrium model
will reduce gdp by 1.62 over the long
term
that biden tax plan by 2030 would lead
to about 7.7 percent less after tax
income for the top 1 percent
and about 1.9 decline in after-tax
income for all taxpayers on average a
hoover institute analysis says
that that tax plan is going to cost the
median family about 6 500 bucks by 2030.
his spending is extraordinary according
to henry olsen writing for the
washington post
the manhattan institute's brian rydell a
former budget staffer used third-party
cost estimates of biden's proposal to
show they total more than 11
trillion dollars over 10 years 11
trillion by the way
the optimistic assessment of how much
money the government will take in
in addition to what they're currently
taking in because the tax increase is
just 3.3 trillion dollars
so that is an overrun of 8 trillion
biden is going to target your religious
liberty he is
his own website says quote religious
freedom is a fundamental american value
but
states have inappropriately used broad
exemptions to allow businesses medical
providers social service agencies
state and local government officials and
others to discriminate against lgbtq
people
so what you're going to get is your
church being cracked down upon your
business being cracked down upon
religious liberty is on the ballot
biden's on the wrong side of it
on guns biden has actually been pretty
consistently anti-gun despite all of his
talk about owning shotguns and then
saying blatantly ridiculous things about
guns such as
blow a shotgun blast through your door
or fire a shotgun from your balcony or
cops should shoot to wound
biden openly says he'll put beta
o'rourke like gun confiscation beta
o'rourke in charge of guns
i want to make something clear
i'm going to guarantee you this last
year's scene of this guy
you're going to take care of the gun
problem with me you're going to be the
one who leads this effort
i'm counting on you i'm counting on you
on labor
biden intends on giving away the store
to organize labor particularly public
sector unions he opposes right-to-work
legislation that allows you not to
sign over union wages if you're not a
member of a union in many states he's in
favor of card check
which allows union heads to bully you
into voting in favor of a union no
blind balloting for unions he wants to
raise the minimum wage he wants to make
collective bargaining with public sector
unions mandatory so states don't get to
decide whether to bargain
with a public sector union on schooling
biden wants to hand
billions and billions and billions more
dollars to teachers unions he opposes
federal funding for charter schools he
opposes school vouchers
on immigration biden is now pushing hard
for amnesty for 11 million illegal
immigrants he said this in the last
debate
i've made it very clear within 100 days
i'm going to send to the united states
congress
a pathway to citizenship for over 11
million undocumented people
and all of those so-called dreamers
those daca kids they're going to be
immediately certified again to be able
to stay
in this country and put on a path to
citizenship so
there you are the four reasons not to
vote for joe biden typical politician
complete with all the corruption two
jobs been wrong on every single foreign
policy issue of his entire life three
you cannot trust him to be a bulwark for
moderation he's not even a bulwark in
defense of his own moderation
from the past he will immediately dump
out of that if the political winds shift
against him
and four his open agenda is incredibly
radical and you may not like president
trump you may not want to vote for
president trump you may not vote for
president trump but please
think about whether or not you should
vote for joe biden because
a vote against president trump and in
favor of joe biden is still
a vote in favor of joe biden well thanks
so much for watching if you want to see
more content
like this let us know down in the
comments